the man who was the first baseman for
the New York Yankees that day and that
eventually the second baseman in the
restart of the game he's none other than
current Miami Marlins manager Don
Mattingly how are you don Goodrich how
are you doing can you believe it's been
35 years at the end time to definitely
March it all and that's for sure it
seems like it's yesterday really
honestly that day in stadiums so what's
your recollection walk me through your
perspective when Brett came to bat that
day the I guess my clearest memory is
Billy had had noticed you know maybe a
day before or two days before that that
George had pints are way off the bat and
nowadays it's it's it's okay but then
then you couldn't do it and he was just
waiting for the right time and as soon
as that York hit the Homer there comes
Billy looking at the bat I think it was
Tim McClelland behind the plate he puts
it across the plate it was too high and
he called him out and then George doing
the the swim move coming out of the
dugout with his arms flailing and I
think Billy just enjoyed that so much
being able to pull that off that that's
probably my best memory of it so did you
know that he it's simple like when Billy
was coming out of the dugout after that
like oh my gosh he's gonna actually try
and get this thing overturned did you
yeah I think we're pretty much all news
I think great deeds are either billiard
maybe even Greg nettles had had noticed
it and they talked about it and then
when he came out it was you pretty much
knew what was happening so I mean so
what happened next
from your did you you must have had a
really good view of George Brett coming
out of the dugout right Don oh yeah from
there you know kind of chaos you
remember a couple of things all sudden
somebody's running up the runway the
tunnel with the bat Gaylord Perry Hall
of Famer Gaylord Perry took the bat but
they took the bat we're running up and
people are chasing for the bat and and
all kinds of things like that
it was just kind of chaos after that and
you know they're the game's over you
know and we find out later that we got
to replay it
so what before we get to that part Don
Mattingly Marlins manager here on a 35th
anniversary of the famed pine tar game
right here on the Rich Eisen show what
was it like in the clubhouse afterwards
just pretty you know just exciting end
up winning the game but you know the
talkin obviously was what had happened
and how it happened and and I remember a
whole lot about exactly the way I went
in the clubhouse but it was just pretty
much the talk of a clubhouse that day
mm-hmm I bet I bet and Billy as you said
was just like the cat ate the canary huh
Billy Martin Steve exactly and you know
Billy always was looking to get an edge
somehow some way you know one of those
guys knew the rule book in and out and
it was you know exactly what you said it
was like so you know Billy was the
candidate the canary like that and so
okay so then when you found out you how
to replay it
what was your recollection of that day
when you're when you were told to get to
second base Don you know kind of fun
actually you know you it's like you're
back to kid days you needed one out and
I think Guidry's and sinners they put
Guidry in center
I'm not sure the reasons for all this
because I'm sure there were certain guys
you couldn't use you know because of you
had to go back I guess and figure out
who was in line I'm 15 out of the lineup
that day maybe guys weren't even on your
roster I'm not sure of all the the rules
with that day but I didn't know that it
was a little different you know playing
second base for one out and I remember
Gator and center yeah I think you are
the first left-handed second baseman to
have played at that position in a long
time and then I think you're the only
one since Don to be very honest with you
Oh Lou got the idea of throwing me over
at third you can do that you can go to
third yeah Piniella huh from back in the
day
what do you
many recollections of the way
Steinbrenner handled this situation done
I I don't I don't remember any any of
that but I was pretty young I think
obviously it was my rookie year and so
then you probably didn't have probably
some of the older guys had a better
better a handle on that but I didn't
have any idea of what was going on with
that but I guess you got you must have
gotten a heck of a I guess welcome to
New York City baseball right your rookie
season for sure anything with Billy well
New York was probably enough for me
right there and just being in the big
leagues but definitely your first year
or Billy the manager you definitely see
a different side of things
compared to minor league baseball so do
you have you ever had any conversations
with George Brett about this since then
Oh
conversations with George maybe had a
few cocktails now and then but I
remember talking about that probably
talking about anything other than that i
McClellan and all because obviously you
retired just a few years ago but he was
in Major League Baseball till 2013 no no
no real conversations about it there
also no I think it may be that day I
think they there was a I don't know if
it was the same mount pars there may be
different and there was some type of I
heard there was some type of deal where
they had they were we were gonna
challenge every base that he touched
every base and those umpires weren't
there but there was some kind of
affidavits in there he had touched every
base you know yes time Brenner was gonna
sue him and Billy Martin yeah that's
exactly what happened is that they had
the umpires from the original day sign
an affidavit to say that that George
Brett did in fact touch every base
because I guess that was the way that
everything started with the restart was
an appeal play at almost every base done
there was something with it that again
typical Billy probably typical George at
that time yeah I mean I do remember
though being a kid well you know a
teenager a Yankee fan die hard I was
pissed that Quisenberry was allowed to
close you guys out that day because he
was he was on the
list 35 years ago today ah see I didn't
know that but I do remember I think I
had like a like a 15 game hitting streak
going into that game I didn't get a hit
that day and so it went back you know I
would have had like a 26 or something
like that 26 so you did but you didn't
get a nap did you get it at bat in the
bottom of the night I did I did against
Quisenberry right yeah that's right I'm
sure I ground it out somewhere he was
it's I love this sort of stuff man I
mean this is just I couldn't even
imagine with you know 24 hour or 24/7
coverage and Twitter and social media
what this would have been like you know
if this had happened today yeah I would
have definitely been a different thing
with social media for sure that would
have that sure definitely would have
trended right I definitely think it
would have it would have trended that is
for darn sure before I let you go I know
you got a game what what what can you
tell fans in South Florida about the
state of the Marlins with you with Jeter
in the front office and all the
conversation about about the roster and
what was done in the offseason and how
you guys are trying to compete what
would you what would you give me an
update on on this situation Don oh if I
was talking to the fans of South Florida
I definitely say you know you were in a
great spot I think what Derek and new
ownership and put in place here is a is
something that's going to be sustainable
you know what we were doing in the
winter it had to be done and you hate to
say like that because we let some really
good players go but we've got some
really good players back
Derek talks about building this thing
from the bottom up being totally
professional running this organization
as professional players playing the game
that way it's a we're in a good spot
right now it's I think we probably
exceeded expectations I think everybody
thought we were going to lose 120 games
or something but we've been really
competitive the guys have played
extremely hard it's one of the things
Eric talks about is we're going to be in
a competitive environment where
you know you're always need to show who
you are and keep playing because there's
going to be guys coming and we want to
build this thing you know from that
standpoint where it's a competitive
environment where guys know they have to
perform or there's somebody else coming
have you used the you know I know
Steinbrenner always liked having
football mentality and his managers have
you used like it's the typical football
well nobody expects us to do anything
have you used that with your players at
any point this season I definitely
didn't have to I think with all the talk
you know going into spring training you
know and I think teams looked at it
again like we were going to be a doormat
like it was going to be a circus and our
guys have came out we prepared the way
we would if we were right on the verge
of winning the championship the way you
have to we have to you know we've looked
at it as a teaching environment
development environment where we got to
continue to get better we got to prepare
to play every day we got to play good
baseball make good baseball decisions as
you're playing the game I think our guys
have been great they played extremely
hard and and to be honest with you we're
playing really well what do you think
Steinbrenner would have thought that
you'd be managing for a team that Derek
Jeter was part of our ownership group
what do you think he would have thought
about that I think you know like this
both to be in New York in some way shape
or form George is very loyal to to his
players and the people that had success
in New York but I think you know I look
at it a lot like yoga you got to you got
to go and make your own path increase
your own environment but what Derek's
doing I think is there's a lot of Yankee
involved with what we're doing you know
what we're doing in the minor leagues
the professionalism we want guys to play
with how we expect them to work and
prepare there's a lot of New York down
here well I mean and it's I'm just
wondering if it's interesting at all to
you if it's losted you I mean your last
season with the Yankees he was getting a
cup of coffee getting this tell wet in
in a playoff series with you against the
Seattle Mariners I mean do you ever look
at it and a Jeter and go my gosh that's
my boss ever it's a little different
start now
with that but you know you have so much
respect for Derek and the way he played
the game
the way he handled himself and I got to
see I feel like I've seen this thing
from the very beginning from the from
the you know the first year that he
signs
I played rookie ball but the next year
he's in big league camp every year so I
watched his pretty much whole
development you know kind of from one
spring to the next to the next then all
of a sudden he's getting up for a cup of
coffee and back and then he's back up
and you could just see him getting
better and better and it's actually it's
a lot of fun working for Derek because
he expects a lot and in the way it
should be right he knows the game when
you talk to him about what's going on
with our players he sees it there's no
there's no doubt that he's watching
every game and what's going on with this
and he expects us to play the game the
right way and play hard and it's been a
lot of fun working for him and you know
I don't know to wrap this up how to ask
this question but I'll ask it anyway
because you saw me on the field in Los
Angeles when you and the manager there
and my wife was pregnant at the time and
I told you who what the middle name of
my child was going to be and she's now
four or turning five you know what turn
middle name is dawn right you been a few
girls little Mattingly's and a lot of
dogs and cats kids out there and you
know what it's always an honor that
someone would think enough of you two to
put your name within your family and it
really is something that I'm always like
kind of caught off guard and taken back
with and very proud of well you know I
just only wish that there could have
been some sort of camera device inserted
into the baby announcements that were
sent to my in-laws who are all red sox
fans when they opened up that baby great
I know
unfortunately don't have it but and just
I guess bring it all full circle we did
named her and my wife had no idea that
this is the name of your son I believe
her first name is Taylor
Oh perfect my first son Taylor Mattingly
Eisen tme is her initials too much Eisen
which is what she is already to be very
honest with you Mattingly charities org
right is that those are your charities
that's your charitable function what can
you tell me about that as we as we wrap
up our chat here dawn oh thank you I
appreciate you give me an opportunity
something we've done we're working we
start an RBI program first and it's
something I've always felt like the the
inner-city kids I want to give them the
opportunity to play and be taught the
game we've expanded into education and
reading programs in my hometown in
Evansville working definitely with the
underserved kids we want to we want to
bring to give those kids opportunity
that there's a world out there for them
and about making good decisions and good
choices but give them the opportunity to
be involved with some things and be
involved with people that are gonna give
him that shot and and open their eyes to
the whole world and that anything can be
accomplished through work through
education through the right attitude and
I appreciate gave me a chance absolutely
done that's the least I can do Mattingly
charities org to learn more in the
mattingly charities is the Instagram and
mattingly charity is on Facebook it's
great to chat with you at all as always
done thanks for strolling down pine tar
memory lane with us here today that
Marlins manager Don manacled Arthur
Mattingly is all of us from back in the
Yankee days would say here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience